وفي ردود الفعل دعا تجمع المهنيين
السودانيين قاده القوات المسلحه والدعم
السريع والشرطه والمخابرات العامه الى
تغليب صوت العقل من جهه قال فضل الله برمت
ناصر رئيس حزب الامه القومي للمشاركين في
الاجتماعات التي شاهدها الحزب اليوم
وسيشهدها غدا ستجري اتصالات بقيادتي الجيش
والدعم السريع لحذفهما على حل خلافاتهما
سلميا
الامر يتطلب
[موسيقى]
جمع الصفوه الوطني
مدنيين وعسكريين
ولاهميه الموضوع
قرروا بان
ينعقد قدم الجمعه في تمام الساعه الثانيه
بعد صلاه الجمعه
كل من تسمح له الظروف بحضور هذا الاجتماع
زائدا الذين حضروه
وانه هنالك حمله
تناسب كل ابناء الوطن
السياسيين والاعلاميين وكل المهتمين
بالشان السوداني بان يحضروا الاجتماع الذي
تقرره غدا الجمعه الساعه الثانيه لاهميته
لانه
يتناول القضيه الوطنيه التي تهم كل ابناء
الوطن